[Musique]
ça fait des heures et des heures qu'on
roule sur ces routes de terre et de
sable qui nous mène au site qui est
devenu depuis deux décennies
schott officiel diffusé ce jour ci
kazakhstan dont on est ton coeur des
steppes du kazakhstan il n'y a
absolument rien autour de nous mais
c'est un vaste terrain où on a identifié
13 sites potentiels ou pourrait se poser
là sur you atterrissage prévu à 22h48 55
secondes exactement réglé au quart de
tour
la journée s'annonçait spectaculaire dès
les toutes premières heures un soleil de
plomb et très peu de vent la capsule
soyouz est apparu ou d'une haute head
telle une montgolfière qui se baladent
et simplement danser quelques temps en
temps du sud qui semble être une énorme
explosion et sa famille
ça y est le page principale ce qui est
ouvert au sol c'était la course contre
la mort valls d'hélicoptères et les
camions tout le monde était prêt quand
elle a finalement touché
david saint jacques est sorti le dernier
visiblement fidh
ça sent l'essence était ouverte en vue
du ciel terral m'en tombent du ciel une
fois une fois qu on se convainc que
c'est pas dangereux
stéphane le bain d'abord nous sommes
chanceux d'être venu mais c'est un peu
nous et puis mais je suis suisse qui me
surprend c'est l'odeur du foin ici c'est
super bon
[Musique]